womöglich ein durchbruch bei corona
impfstoff wie die universität oxford am
montag bekannt gab haben die britischen
wissenschaftler einen wirksamen und
sicheren impfstoff gegen das corona
virus gefunden
der britische premierminister boris
johnson zeigte sich auf twitter erfreut
und zuversichtlich das sind sehr gute
nachrichten ein großes kompliment an
unsere brillanten und welt führenden
wissenschaftler und forscher es gibt
keine garantien wir sind noch nicht am
ziel weitere versuche werden notwendig
sein
aber das ist ein wichtiger schritt in
die richtige richtung jetzt soll das
mittel an weiteren menschen getestet
werden darunter rund 10.000 probanden in
großbritannien auch in brasilien haben
weitere tests mit mehreren tausend
freiwilligen begonnen klar es ist für
uns sehr wichtig zu erfahren ob der
impfstoff wirkt wie gut er wirkt und bei
wem jede information die wir erhalten
werden wir mit anderen forschern teilen
international gibt es ein rennen von
wissenschaftlern und pharmaunternehmen
um ein crooner impfstoff das mittel aus
oxford zählt wohl zu den
aussichtsreichsten kandidaten